We've just got news of some more cut scenes
from IT, including an extended quarry scene
with a funny moment from Eddie and a creepy-sounding
Bar Mitzvah ceremony involving Stan.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm talking about several deleted
scenes likely to appear in the Director's
Cut that's just been announced for the new
IT movie.
Director Andy Muschietti revealed that we
can look forward to around 15 minutes of extra
footage in his extended cut that will be appearing
on the Blu-ray release.
Just before I jump in, quick warning that
I'll be discussing spoilers from the movie,
so take care if you've not seen IT yet.
Also keep watching for details on the winner
of my Pennywise Funko Pop giveaway.
The first cut scene that Andy Muschietti revealed
in an interview with Yahoo Movies is where
Stan addresses the guests at his Bar Mitzvah
ceremony and "he delivers a speech [where
he basically blames] all the adults [in] Derry"
for the murders and disappearances in the
town.
Muschietti also said this deleted scene "has
a great resolution", which makes me wonder
whether it's because Pennywise or the creepy
woman who terrorised him previously suddenly
appears in the congregation at the synagogue
while he's giving his speech.
If you remember, in the theatrical release,
Stan had his first encounter with IT at the
beginning of the movie via the creepy woman
who emerged from the painting at the synagogue
where he was practising for his Bar Mitzvah.
So, perhaps the evil entity IT makes an appearance
again to disrupt Stan's speech or turn the
crowd at the synagogue against him.
IT is often present in Derry whenever a horrific
event is happening or about to happen.
For example, there was the scene where Henry
Bowers and his gang were beating up Ben on
the bridge and a pair of adults driving by,
just look away.
As they drive past, Pennywise's signature
balloon floats up inside the car, showing
how IT is at work making people either blind
to the violence or just normalising it.
I also wonder whether Stan's attempt to reveal
this truth about IT is the reason why Pennywise
specifically targets him later and tries to
eat him when the Losers go down into the sewers
to find Bev.
Let me know if you've got any theories about
the scene.
I certainly can't wait to see it in full on
the Blu-ray.
Muschietti has also revealed that he enjoys
filming alternate takes and on IT he gave
the actors freedom to improvise during their
scenes.
As an example of this, the director explained
that he filmed a really funny extended scene
of the moment where the Losers jump off the
cliff into the quarry water below.
In the movie, Eddie, Ben, Bill, Stan and Richie
are standing on the cliff above the quarry,
having a spitting match, and arguing over
who should jump first, before Bev turns up
and jumps in ahead of them all.
In the extended scene, the moment was opened
up and, according to Muschietti, "after the
spitting contest it escalates into something
that is completely weird [… and] is so funny.
Jack Grazer [who plays] Eddie […] does something
that is completely bonkers."
I wonder if this deleted moment will show
the boys taking their competitive natures
to even greater extremes than the spitting
contest.
Or could an earlier script give a clue as
to what this deleted moment might be?
In that earlier screenplay, at this point
in the film Eddie worries about whether it's
safe for Ben to go in the water because of
his cuts and Ritchie tells him to shut up
and stop going on about grey water, which
is what Eddie had been unhappy about earlier
in the movie when they were in the sewers.
So, I'm thinking that the extended joking
around by Eddie could riff on this, showing
an even more exaggerated side of his hypochondria.
After all, it seems like Jack, who plays Eddie,
has a real flair for working in the moment,
as according to co-screenwriter Gary Dauberman,
that line where Eddie mistakes the word 'gazebo'
for 'placebo' was also something that just
happened on the day.
According to producer Barbara Muschietti,
several scenes featuring Bill's parents were
also cut from the theatrical release, though
they'll likely appear on the DVD.
In the final film, the scene where Bill has
made a model of the Derry sewers in the family
garage shows us that there's a conflict between
Bill and his father who's exasperated by his
son's belief that Georgie is still alive.
However, further moments were deleted from
the movie that focused on the growing distance
between Bill and his parents after the traumatic
disappearance of Georgie.
Speaking to Collider, producer Muschietti
said the cut scenes show Bill trying to make
their situation better but his parents are
just unable to cope.
By the way, when I was reading an earlier
script for the movie, I noticed it included
a scene where Bill speaks to his parents about
planning their annual trip to Acadia National
Park, but neither his mother nor father can
face even thinking about something their missing
child loved so much and they end up walking
away, leaving Bill alone in the room.
So, I'm guessing this is the kind of scene
which Muschietti is referring to as having
been given the chop from the theatrical release.
Now, are you excited for the director's cut
of IT?
And which actors would you like to play the
adult Losers in Chapter 2?
I'm looking forward to reading your thoughts
in the comments below.
You can also follow me on Twitter and my handles
are on the screen here.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget to hit the
thumbs-up button and subscribe, and check
out some more videos you might like here.
The winner of my Pennywise Funko Pop giveaway
is on the screen right now, so if that's you,
send me a message with your details and I'll
get the prize sent out to you.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!